welcome to this video playing G K 2 K
this is Iceland yep Iceland so let's
play a main line William black ok let's
go for the brave yeah exactly this
position just some days ago against
Grand Master Blaster behoort the other
team veteran GM and I got a very nice
position with blacks which ultimately I
feel to convert was a bit of a shame
early ok so here we have a typical
brayer position where ya both sides then
we have all the pieces on the board
that's what I'm trying to say very very
complex strategic game does he want to
take don't think I'm afraid of that all
that much
b6 looking at t6e with the bishop at you
is it a problem neither 496 is an idea
also with somebody I know it takes ok
pawn takes Knight takes pawn things in
context ok I can take SOT maybe before
us as idea but doesn't seem to be the
case I wonder if c5 a threat I think it
is so I'm going to play c5 myself enum
ideas Knight f6 night f4e 6d four yes we
have similar intentions
definitely
hmm I is it it is a bit quicker than the
nidus is a real pain down but they maybe
I can do this and go Quinn j5 Queen 85
isn't that annoying against the pawn
let's see how he responds to that night
only five is nice but this is the tech
all that much yeah now a 4x do I just
take it I think I do well why not
i think i'm just a pawn up I have night
at 460 form as well I should have some
options David that week square on deform
just as he has the idea here with white
I wonder am Queen Queen anywhere see one
I mean IDF overcome with the tempo on
the bishop which is also lies he might
read to pin leave it yeah maybe I should
do that do that first pin his Bishop
before he moves it and i'm congested a
bit it's probably helpful
she takes it I'm everything gets opened
up yeah now nice to be three with I have
squares especially at a 40 93 okay he's
scared I'll go back image I've got the
good cover here on c5 that I have to do
before you place please my 85
potentially yeah d for that is the
square okay now do I take it not sure
thank you I cover see if I first and
then see what happens let's see if I was
attacked by Bishop enjoyed
okay so he needs to do something that's
absolutely clear is this right though I
mean takes what if you do clean take so
I have 92 for example to tell the tech
so yeah you see threatening much not yet
clean yeah he preserves this
understandably so now I think I should
take him get rid of this dangerous thing
and now probably see form time learning
okay ready to be active so let's do it
now we have to shoot g7 this is hanging
now k right it doesn't feel all that
important Queen age 6
put the night g fiber think
it should be pretty okay i can actually
keep it keep the pawn there's no need to
give it back immediately
okay neither three I want to threaten
let's do it that should do the trick
kick late okay that was still tricky
very tricky very complicated middle game
position here out of the Braille
oftentimes these are super complex all
pieces on the board yeah you played see
form yeah so this yeah this was possible
be four or c5 those moves the engine
give c5 is good for why am I was I was
thinking about this but I didn't feel
that this is too dangerous because of
this one but see fire soon huh that's
probably strong this is not looking good
very dangerous yeah yeah I'm okay
interesting achieve engine still thought
white was ok before now I'm starting to
be quite substantially better yeah so
the the real issue is somewhere around
here of course he had 35 that was really
cool idea now he was quite clearly
better that was important and here here
I'm okay but
necessarily better according to the
computer it's a bit surprising how does
it offend we should see one what is the
compensation if I do this I am 23 okay
my queen is no square and this is going
to pin me so I cannot take and we could
move with it quite clearly if you can
ignore it but yeah I mean I was the pawn
up interestingly enough g3 still seems
to be compensation now it makes sense it
prevent that that's a good idea the
other way it turned out and why did not
have enough for the plan I think ok guys
thanks for watching